So I'm just going to show you a few things. So let's say
we have a variable called price.
So this to 1,000?
and
next I will type in print.
prices is a very
simple example, but I just want to do this.
To show you something in the slides.
Now when I declare this variable and I run it.
both of these things
will be put in temporary storage when the program is
running.
Okay.
and when The Interpreter processes the
line that comes right after it what it's going to do is it's going
to
access the random access memory
to see to what this variable price
is pointing and then print the contents of contents of that. Okay?
So very basic stuff.
Okay, but I'll tell you why I'm doing this.
So when we come back to the slides here.
Let's say this is you have a program and you've declared two vowels. You have
a variable called price.
Whose value is 1,000 and the variable
called user whose value is the string John?
Okay, so whatever you create your program.
During runtime will be put into temporary storage.
Okay, so
these are 100 and John or both
data, but so are price and user.
now
what we also want to know is that every thing that
is putting temporary storage has associated with an address.
Okay.
and
we call these variables.
That's the value of the variable.
And we call these the pointers. So a pointer is an address
in memory.
Okay.